one of the frustrations of a wildlife
photographer is you're constantly using
telephoto lenses looking down this
barrel look at this photograph this is
what we as natural history
photographer's dream of Nick Nichols was
able to get intimate and able to get
close therefore you've got this
beautiful blue sky you've got elephants
in the background there's texture to
this picture that you seldom see and
that's because of closeness of patients
and the ability to know this animal and
come in with a wide-angle lens Carsten
Peter is a wild man he will go to the
depths of the earth to the crystal caves
of Mexico because he just loves
adventure and because of this curiosity
and this intensity he takes us into
these crystal caves more than 120
degrees he has to wear a special suit to
keep him cool he can only stay down
there for less than an hour but look at
what he's found did you have any idea
that a place like this existed one of
the most difficult things to do in a
photograph is humor Fritz Hoffman has
lived in China for more than 20 years
here he finds for young people being
deep programmed for online use their
spending too much time on their
computers something many of us can
relate to for years John and Eva have
photographed elephant seals look at this
photograph it's like a stage it's
otherworldly
cannot believe places like this exist
and then as you go through the frame you
keep coming back to those two huge
elephant seals my one regret a
publishing this photograph in 2008 was
we couldn't publish it big enough ray
Gerard has lived in photographed in
china for years he found this village
that is a beautiful example of human
ingenuity those are water lines the
villagers put this together themselves
it was to solve the problem of dirty
water with clean water and then look at
the way greg has composed the photograph
it makes me want to look in this village
to go there to meet these people who
built this line in his digital age
robbed kendrick says no i want to take
the time-honoured film photography large
to medium format and photograph the
tomorrow people in Mexico he wants to
take photographs that will last that are
testament to a time that's changing how
much longer will we be able to make this
photograph this is a man's
honest-to-goodness life there's an old
expression of photography f8 and be
there meaning the f-stop f8 you point
your camera you make the picture that's
it
but this picture is much more
complicated than that Barney OH
indonesia indonesia is the third largest
emitter of greenhouse gases in the world
because of deforestation this is a
picture that many people in Borneo do
not want Matias clung to make and now
he's seeing it going up in smoke for
palm oil this is a document of our time